i didn't forgive my mom
for uh
for the morning i killed a guy that went
to prison and she was watching and she
didn't do nothing
and you forgive her for that i had to
kill the guy man and she was watching
and when i was screaming for help she
didn't do it she didn't do nothing she
just watched
him and two other guys gets over my
sister's door
i got shut the door
about 4 00 at 4 30 am
and i went outside about 10 minutes
later man they come around the corner
with [ __ ] i wake up i mean they were
drunk and high and they tackled me
they stabbed me in my chest and
the guy one guy pulled a knife out of my
chest and he slipped and fell on the
knife because it was raining
and my mom was watching with her
sister-in-law her brother my brother and
the neighbors were watching nobody did
nothing yeah i did 15 years
went down i got arrested as a kid and
got out 36 and a half years old
spent all my life in that race
and i need to forgive her for it
so well i needed her let's say
i needed her to save me
she didn't save me
and you were protecting yourself and
your sister yeah
have you have you tried to find healing
in some in any way
yeah after drugs but it won't work
i won't die
i can't i won't die
i just keep going man keep living with
that memory of my mom watching
watch one dude stab me in my chest
remember when i go it worked cool man
i have a very um
tangled up thing with
my
my husband who died in 2014 and he was
an alcoholic
so
i think i still
need to i mean this thing i feel i have
horrible guilt for not
managing to save him even though i know
that he can't save people
so i feel really bad and awful that he
that he's died in the way that he did
but also um i think i still am kind of
angry with him for kind of destroying
our life so
so you know i probably still need to
forgive him a bit
for what happened but also forgive
myself for not being able to sort it out
there's an analogy which i was given
which is one of the most helpful things
in grief because people sort of think of
it as something that kind of gets
smaller and easier to carry over time
but i i find that's unhelpful because it
doesn't really go away so you know
instead you need to think of like
grief as like a ball in a jar and at the
beginning um when it first happens the
the ball fills the whole jar and it's
like takes up your entire life and then
sort of people would think the ball
starts to shrink but actually it's the
jar of your life starts to grow around
it so your life expands you have new
experiences so the grief is always there
and it never really goes away and it's
always its thing but you have more life
around it that helps makes it easier to
carry
to forgive is my brother i have a scar
on my face because of him
and i always forgive him because i love
him but
the scar on my face just like
is a reminder of like
kind of the
trauma
and
the abuse that we both go through
how aggressive
we could be in like very fragile times
he builds up emotion and
i also build up emotion but i don't take
it all in other people i mostly just
take it on myself but he takes that on
other people
like where he blames me for a lot of
things
that
are mistaken but
it's really like you can't blame
somebody else
you can't
um
not a person but
in a way not to be like sexist or
anything but just
men
just need to forgive men being
encountered with a lot of different guys
you know dating wise i would just like
to forgive men for the way that they've
treated me
in a certain way
and to be more clear about that just as
in
not respecting women's boundaries not
considering their feelings and
just walking on the street and being
honked at or going to the bar and the
bartender's calling you
things like that like that's why i need
to forgive men because i think that
they don't understand the type of trauma
that something like that could do to
another person
and they all not all of them do it but
there's been a lot of men that i know
that are good people
but still have that same type of persona
on women as in you could call them
straight off the street whistle at them
and you think that it's okay to treat
another female like that
so i think i need to forget or forgive
um like people who like were mean to me
in high school or like bull with me
because i used to be really like mad at
people for it i don't know now that i've
like
you know it's been a year since then
like
it feels like almost something was wrong
with in their life and that's what they
were taking out on me one of the things
that like really brings my mind is when
um
one time i was wearing like the sweater
um and it was maybe in like 10th grade
and this guy um
i actually got a compliment from
somebody and i sit down next to this guy
who was like the cool kid
um and he told me how do you always
dress like you're homeless
and i don't know it was just like really
like because i was really self-conscious
he like hit where it was like very like
a soft spot for me
why was that a soft spot for you i
actually was like living with my mom and
then she was drinking with like the
partner she was with and she would
always like change partners because of
that like i had to move out to a
friend's house with my sister
and it kind of almost felt like you know
we're sleeping on people's couches so i
guess it kind of did feel like i was
homeless at the time
but i actually just thought about it now
they asked me about it really so you
didn't connect that yeah i didn't
connect it at all next time somebody
tells me that um i'll take it as a
compliment honestly i know right
i'm not from
i mean you know what i want to say um
i want to forgive i had a
i had a teacher in my life that was
there i mean he he yelled at children he
was kind of mean but it was
it was years ago i just need i need to
let it go i need to learn to let that go
i mean as embarrassing as it is i have
to admit i've had
several dreams just
of me telling this person how much i
hate them and just because it feels like
in a just world i want them to know
that
they i feel like they made my life worse
but i know
that that's that's silly and that
shouldn't matter and it shouldn't make
my life better making their life worse
probably my dad i think that's like a
pretty
common response i would imagine the
person i would need to forgive is my dad
my dad my father and the reason is is
that he was
raised in a very repressed
german-russian christian family
he never could understand that i was gay
um he used a lot of physical
and verbal abuse and violence towards me
and it has affected my whole life
and i should forgive him because it
would probably clear a lot of baggage
for me but it's hard to forgive him
because it has such long-lasting impact
that shows up all the time
and so he he abused you because he knew
you were gay or
[Applause]
yeah
there wasn't just a moment there were
lots of moments there were lots of years
of it and the way i got through it was
by
both becoming really introverted but
also becoming an attack animal so
somewhere between that he would corner
me and then i would just go into ugly
rages
like when my parents split it gave me a
very messed up image of like what
men should be like and
how i should be treated as a person that
i think i put myself in abusive
relationships and so now my views on
love are like super misconstrued but it
started like all the way from then you
know
so i think that if i let him go
when i'm being loved correctly at least
i will know
my dad and i have a good relationship
but we don't get super deep emotionally
and at some point in time i'm gonna have
to be like hey man like can we do that
um that's probably my answer have you
ever seen a movie called smoke signals
no um the very final scene there's a
poem and i don't exactly
remember i think it's called something
like
if we forgive our fathers like what's
next it's interesting you should watch
it
like my dad left the country he was like
18
you know and he was kind of kind of like
a weekend kind of dad you only see him
part time
he was like my best friend too so
and it's interesting too because like
i'm like a point in my life where i'm
really like 25 is like you kind of
answering like a different phase in my
opinion like 18th like 24ish that's like
kind of figuring things out you're going
to adult world 25 and beyond i don't
know maybe i'm like 30 32
it's like it's like sophomore year of
like adulting if that makes sense it's
kind of like a different phase
but yeah you just learn more about
yourself and you're like man i have this
like all this [ __ ] that i need to get
out there i don't know any trauma to
talk to about it
but
yeah i mean i i think i do forgive him
deep down
but it's like you just want to have that
conversation
it's just those little things it's just
like
you know
it's like i hate it i'm going to college
now or like hey dad i'm going to the
military now or just like just be there
like in your life you know
like i'd be the best dad in the world i
would i mean i'm tooting my own horn
right but like my kid's gonna be a champ
my kids if there's gonna be multiple you
know they're all gonna be
great little bastards
they are they're gonna be phenomenal
like you're gonna get like 100 of my
love and devotion everything
probably my father for uh for killing my
mother
i'm sorry was that probably my father
for killing my mother shot my mom twice
and then she took himself out if i think
about it it's like i
i remember just like it just happened me
and my brother we were we were going to
see you since 11 that morning in the
theater and um
my sister called us about an hour into
the movie and said that um
mom and dad weren't answering their
phones she's received calls from both
their work it wasn't like them to not
show up for work because they were
always always at work i always do it
really i remember about the mouth in the
house like we closed this one bridge to
get to her to their condo
and um i just felt my stomach drop
like like i knew something like terrible
that happened i remember them yelling
man ma'am are you okay so like for a
split second i thought
i thought she was all right and i
thought things were like maybe okay like
but um it wasn't like i remember i tried
to
run upstairs and push through the
officers they tackled me on the stairs
and didn't want me to go in there said i
don't need to see what see that was in
there
um
how old were you
at the time i was 22.
you never saw it coming
it was
it's pretty wild yeah for quite a few
years and
i'd say for the first 10 years like it
was really hard to even speak about it
without just breaking down um
you kind of gave up on a lot of things
that i had going for me like i just
kind of like lost
like lost interest in care for a man
ended up homeless and like strung out on
drugs and then
quite a few different things and it was
uh i i mean i can't blame that exactly
but i knew that was like yes
part of my thing it was like i just
wanted to run with everything you've
been through you still want to forgive
your dad
yeah i mean i can't like i don't know i
guess like um
as far as what i know about forgiveness
and stuff i guess like you know we're
supposed to forgive people like before
we pass away or whatever like
you know so i don't know i don't want
anything like
feeling ill in my conscience or running
or anything like i can't say i hate him
like i hate what he did i don't
understand it just totally baffles me
like
you know especially like when i used to
see him like wake up every morning and
read his bible for like an hour four in
the morning every day like before he
started the day and and stuff like i
just don't hey
it don't make sense to me i get
a lot of it but
i don't know what he was thinking like
he was he never really talked a lot to
us like about his feelings or anything
he was he was like
ex-military and like his in around the
time when they like
basically beat it in their head that you
know that any kind of emotions were just
a sign of weakness so they weren't
supposed to have feelings or anything
like
he's a good dad
for to his kids i mean i can say that
like he did a lot for us and like
always put us first ahead of him but
yeah
other than that it's like i don't know
like like most selfish thing ever like
he didn't have to take her with him if
he wanted to go i mean i don't i don't
know
i never know what really happened that
that day in that room or whatever i just
know like the outcome and what the
police report says and everything here
if you could have one message for
everyone what would it be
um
well life is too short for negativity
and stuff um
um like um if there's anyone in an
abusive relationship like get out before
it's too late i guess um that's
okay thank you so much man i appreciate
you
[Music]
hey everyone thry here i just wanted to
say thank you for watching this episode
i love you all i appreciate you all and
i'll see you next week